um the song lyric is from Adventure Time
and [ __ ] sings it and she says you and I
will always be back then
and it reminds me of my aunt who I lost
the cancer two years ago
it's from a cartoon that I grew up with
and I just I feel so much and it's a
stupid little song but I just love it it
really spoke to me because around the
time she died I heard it again I was
actually re-watching the show and it
just reminds me of her like we're always
gonna be back then
she was amazing she was such a presence
in her life she made an impact on
everyone she was an amazing person and
my family has never been the same
without her and I feel her with me every
day
and that song just really it means a lot
to me
it does
there is a song off of the first
event I know it's a song about her
little brother and it always makes me
think of my little brother so the lyric
is we have the same face I lay it awake
as someone shoved you up against the
wall
quarantined in a bad dream he's half the
man and you're twice as tall
[Music]
I have like the same face as my little
brother he's three years younger than me
but
um I've had people tell us we look like
twins before and he had a really rough
time he got fully pretty bad and
um I always felt bad that like I wasn't
able to protect him all the time
but we're really close now and um yeah
that lyric always gets always gets done
it would be Frank Ocean lenses when he
says I feel that smiles on me I think
about that specifically to someone
because I always feel like when I'm
talking or the Saints I'm like he's just
staring at me and so it makes me like
really think about him when you were
talking to this one person it feels like
yeah because he'll just be like staring
at me admiring me or like I could be
going getting food and I'll turn around
I realize like he's staring at me and
I'm like oh wow he like really doesn't
take his eyes off me and like I'll turn
around he's smiling and so I'm like wow
I can really feel his Smiles on me like
when I'm out there doing something
and this is someone you were with right
now yeah
um so Phoebe Bridgers in her song I see
you
um has this lyric
um I'm too close I can see the brush
Strokes and it just reminds me of this
relationship where I'd kind of like made
up who this person was and
when I really got to know them they were
like nothing like that and it just like
reminds me to like
take time getting to know people and
like not trust what's on the outside
because a person can just be so
different on the inside
there's this song by Carole King oh
you've got a friend she's like you just
call up my name and you know wherever I
am I'll come running to see you again
that's like my friend Alex to me one
time I got stood up on a date and I gave
her like my movie tickets and she
realized it was because I got stood up
so she like basically was like we're
gonna go to this movie and she put on a
really nice dress and like wore a bunch
of makeup and bought me dinner and like
she took me out to that movie that like
my day stood me up on and so she's like
always been a good friend of me
um one lyric that I was thinking of is
from mxm tune song prom dress and it's
like I'm I'm sitting here crying in my
prom dress I'd be the prom queen if
crying was a contest
and it reminds me of this experience I
had when I was a freshman in high school
and this guy asked me to be his
homecoming date and the entire time I
was there he was just hanging out with
another girl and it like made me really
sad and like I went home and I cried and
he like posted that he was hanging out
with her after the dance and that was
like a core memory
[Music]
um the lyric is they sprinkled wound us
in your hair and golden Starlight in
your eyes with blue and it's from the
song close to you and it makes me think
of my dad I saw this baby picture of him
when I was younger where he had like
blonde hair and blue eyes and it just
I I knew him as an adult obviously so
like when he was in like his more
stressed part of his life but that lyric
always made me imagine what he was like
as a child because his parents always
say he was like super vibrant and lonely
so I don't know it just it makes me
think of who he was before I knew him
and it makes me really happy
um I think it's
oh child in this world strange how we
forget the things that made us first
smile and it always makes me think of my
grandmother
um because the whole song um it's called
for Jasmine by boa and it's just about
like this woman talking about like her
love for her child and my I was raised
by my grandmother and then when I was
like 10 my grandma got like diagnosed
like really severe dementia so then from
like when I was like a teenager like a
lot of my well I still am a teenager but
like there's a lot of that kind of
became like I was caring like for her
and I think that like switch I felt like
it was like what she was to me and what
I kind of like became for her you know
I'm sad
um sleep apnea by the beach fossils the
lyric is um sometimes I no longer know
what it means to care about the things
you want to do everybody's living or
they're dead and I'm still in my bed and
I don't have a clue what does it remind
you of myself
I've had moments in life where
it's been so I don't know like how to
explain that everyone has low points in
their life and
um sometimes it feels like
no matter who you talk to
maybe they don't get it but that song
for some reason it just feels like it
grabs graphs grasps the feeling
correctly of just being so depressed and
not wanting to move and having no
motivation
and watching everyone around you kind of
move up in life when you're in your 20s
and things like that so I think that's
why I kind of
really that that lyric touches me a lot
I have to do Kate bushes running up the
hill
um and she says
um she wishes that she could change
bodies with the other person and to feel
their pain and take the pain away from
them that would probably be something
that reminds me of someone who doesn't
remind you of
um I have a lot of uh transsexual
friends that I wonder what it's like to
be in their body and you know to have
them not be in pain in their own body
and if only I could I make a deal with
God and I get him to swap our places
I'll be running up that road I'll be
running up that hill I'll be running up
that building
say if it I Only Could Have
I watched the Moon
let it run my mood
can't stop thinking of you
yeah
who does it remind you of this French
boy that I was in love with over the
summer but I definitely feel like my
soulmate is on the other side of the
world right now he's um oh God
he's um like a very safe person and he
kind of just feels like nighttime and
like a good way
um so whenever I hear that song I think
it's like the feelings that I have for
him and how safe he makes me feel
yeah uh can you what's the song lyric
that reminds you of someone like a
specific someone baby I'm Gonna Leave
You you know that song I'm Gonna Leave
You In The Summertime wait who does it
remind you of
summertime uh I want you around by snow
Allegra
who does it remind you of
who yeah
um this person that I should not like
that uh is a total boy but I you know
what
I do like them I'm guarded so I
shouldn't like him you know what I mean
but anyway that song really hits in a
way that
it's all deep in here I think the song
um You Are My Sunshine which is like a
really old classic song
[Music]
um that reminds me of my mom she used to
sing that a lot to me a lot when I was
younger and I've been thinking about her
a lot recently I just moved to to New
York like two weeks ago for school it's
a really simple lyric I used to mess it
up all the time when I was three I used
to sing it a lot as a kid but I it's
always been very dear to my heart so as
my mom
have you told her that it reminds me of
her no I should I should I should text
her after this yeah Bruce Springsteen
any song Down by the River Born to Run
any of his songs a whole hunk of my life
and a whole particular person
[Music]
oh happens to be her father
I can never remember lyrics but it's it
always has to do with a yearning a love
and a yearning and
sort of doing everything against
society and culture and just loving the
one that you're with literally apart
from the rest of the world
so are you are you still with him the
you're oh no no I'm not actually no it's
just that one of us wanted to have
children and one of us didn't and that's
why I'm sitting next to his
but not mine
we didn't separate because we didn't
love each other anymore that's the
difference between us and a lot of
divorces or separations we loved each
other we had different things we wanted
to do so um after he went off and made
babies
um we opened up a business together and
we built restaurants and we built
restaurants for the last 25 years
together we both ran the same company so
we saw each other and talked to each
other day and night all the time and
then when he had these children although
I hate children hate children I fell in
love with his children one at a time
unexpectedly have no idea why or how now
they are both my God daughters you know
when you talk about Modern Family on
television and everything like that and
everybody has you know two mothers and
14 whatevers we have our own strangely
constructed family but I'm not in his
life in any competitive way I I do not
sleep with him I do not want him I do
not want his daughters I just sort of
slid in in a way where we never we never
knew that there was going to be a slot
for such a person and I never knew I
would want to be in that slot but there
is a slot and somehow I fit into it and
here we are and I have to tell you that
it is 50 years later
okay how do you like that
well we didn't talk politics
politics are like really boring compared
to what I just gave you okay
it was it was a pleasure it really was a
pleasure
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is Soraya and I'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification Bell so you'll
be notified every time I have a new
episode up and follow me on Instagram
I'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything I love you
all and I'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]